fin de cavale dans cette peugeot 306 ou
tout du moins ce qu'il en reste
elle aurait été volée puis incendiée ce
week end par deux adolescents de 16 ans
l'un originaire de la nièvre et l'autre
du département voisin du cher
dans la nuit de vendredi dernier sur un
parking de cette rue de varennes
vauzelles
les deux mineurs à bord de la 306 sont
repérés par une patrouille de
gendarmerie
les choses tournent mal mais le pire est
évité
nous avons dû intervenir sous le signe
de l'urgence puisque les intéressés
tentait de quitter les lieux
ce qui a valu une intervention un peu
délicate dans le sens où le véhicule des
auteurs est venu percuter à nos
véhicules à deux reprises pour
s'extraire du parking et les militaires
qui intervenait ont choisi de ne pas
ouvrir le feu sur le véhicule
parce qu'ils avaient identifié un des
occupants il sera interpellé dimanche
tout comme son complice
les deux mineurs sont des récidivistes
déjà condamné malgré leur saison la
justice a décidé de les incarcérer dans
l'attenté de leur procès et parce que l'
enquête n'est pas terminée les deux
jeunes pourraient en effet avoir commis
d'autres délits
on va s'essayer d'attribuer à ces gens
là vraisemblablement une trentaine de
faits qui se sont déroulés depuis le
début de l'année et sur la fin d'année
dernière pour lesquels il ya de près des
présomptions qui laisse supposer qu'ils
ont participé à ces faits alors à chaque
fois des vols de véhicule suivie d'un
incendie
au moins une trentaine et
vraisemblablement sur 4 départements
nièvre cher allier et puy-de-dôme
puisque la voiture de vendredi soir
venait du puy de dôme quant aux mobiles
des jeunes le jeu semble-t-il de volée
faire des rodéos taux est de brûler la
propriété de trous